i adore documentaries i love
documentaries
um and i really love murder and so you
should listen to tig and cheryl true
story i'm i am going to because it
sounds like you guys you talk a lot
about murder
we do a lot of murder we do a lot like
this week is uh not murder but it's uh
the abercrombie and fitch uh scandal
yeah a lot of scandals a lot of murders
um but it's uh if there's a scandal that
results in a murder i'm ecstatic
and i'm not pro-murderer i don't want to
have the wrong idea
well yeah if i could get away with it
and not be prosecuted i don't want to go
to jail well and also to be very fair um
it's cheryl hines and i on the show so
we're old friends and there's a lot of
nonsense that goes on so it's not like
investigative reporter or npr vibe right
so
we well that's good because we don't do
nonsense on this part exactly
okay but anyone listening to this
podcast it's like oh good i want to hear
it's no it's not that i've noticed
recently that there's this phenomenon
where and i think it really is because
of the netflix of it all but there's
this phenomenon now where they have to
pad out a podcast because
companies channels want streaming
services
i'm saying they don't want two episodes
or one episode of a pi of a documentary
they really want like five or six and if
you can get to seven that's great
so it'll be a really good story
but it'll be a story that could be told
in one in maybe two episodes for sure
and what's happening and what they'll do
is i'll be watching and they'll be like
we sure don't know what happened
to betty lou
no one knows what happened to betty lou
they found her over and which
documentary is that this is called
whatever happened to betty
seven episodes seven episodes and so
they'll say like they found her over
there she was still alive when we found
her what did she say she said derek did
it and we're like derek who and she's
like derek p samuel said and then she
died what was found on the scene a gun
whose gun was it it's registered to a
derrick p samuelson
well
we better think about this
for six episodes
where is derek samuelson live over there
i think we should go arrest him
not just yet first let's talk about the
town
the little town of mcnulty
is a kind of crazy town in 1822 you're
like no go get derek he's right over
there
that's the world now is give us seven
episodes but then there there are there
are documentaries like the staircase
that keep you riveted for 12 or more
episodes you're like oh my god you feel
like a crazy person because you're going
back and forth going that guy didn't do
it oh my gosh he did it
and yeah seen the series like three
times yeah you know what you know what
uh is amazing about
that phenomenon is that
um i think a great documentary is always
going to be someone stumbles on gold
yeah accidentally yeah and not actual
gold
i should be very clear about that yeah
or unless it's a documentary it's not a
bad documentary what about a documentary
called stumbling on gold which follows
people around until the crew finds
someone who stumbles on actual gold but
that's but that's the um or it could be
a comedian trying to find something
funny
yeah stumbling on gold yeah yeah yeah um
that would be the one i would do just
hours and hours of me like i don't think
so it's 20 hours people around 20 hours
of people going i don't know
that's not that's not even a joke
but what else you got but that but
that's the case is that uh
the issue we have in our culture now is
that technology changed in my opinion
and i'm being serious for just half a
second but technology changed so that
um
because of that we have this new
technology suddenly uh you you go from
like the renaissance and all through
history where people had to fight their
way through anonymity to make something
great and occasionally the great was
made and then it endured now we have
this thing which is like that man the
staircase was great that's an amazing
documentary we need 95 more of those
this year yeah and it presupposes that
suddenly
humanity's ability to produce great art
is infinite when it's not the streaming
service is infinite so everyone's
wondering like well why is the bathtub
water so low it's because you made the
bathtub 10 000 times bigger and there's
just the same amount of water so when
you're flipping through channels
um
you know it's going to be rare that you
find
a really great show the good will always
be rare now just i'm going to do this
can take 45 minute more minutes
let's get to the next part of my thesis
when did this become attention you know
and i believe and i say to you
sorry
my my wife and i were um
i mean this is how much i don't watch
things is she was like let's have a
night where we just get in bed and watch
tv together and so i was like okay
and um
and so we got in bed get the remote
we're flipping through the thousands of
channels
past
every rerun every
new show every ev everything on there
and then i piped up genuinely
and said and she makes fun of me for
this
to this day she said or i said um wait
wait go back go back what was that was
that a wagon
and she said what and she went back a
few channels
and
we couldn't find it
and she said what what was it and i said
i don't know i thought i saw a wagon and
i thought
my brain made up that it was a series
of the history of wagons you mean like a
kid's like a radio flyer no
yeah chuck wagon and i thought
what i saw made my brain
think it was the history of wagons and i
was so
i wanted to see that the history of
wagons and then i we were laughing so
hard that that out of everything that we
were flipping through is what that's my
brain
if somebody said
there is a show on the history of wagons
i would
watch that and i would watch because
this is the other thing is she was
saying what
let's say it was the history of wagons
then like what are they going to talk
about see that's how we're different i
love it that my version of that is
flipping through flipping through
flipping through naked lady you know
whatever whatever just if you see some
nudity yeah you're immediately i'm sorry
you go right back to your to your
adolescent brain like there's a naked
lady i just want to see what's going on
and your version of that is hold on a
second i think i saw a wagon
and i would watch another episode that's
like
uh the history of
history of wagons this week
the axle
you know like
i could break it down and watch the
minutia
of how to build a wagon
who who created the wagon who rode in a
wagon
um sounds like you need to make this
show
well i'm all right you're pitching it
she's pitching it right now yeah conan
you want to produce it i the history of
wagons i'll do it you know what i'd like
to do
i'd like to be the narrator
is that possible absolutely i could walk
out and go ah the wagon so often taken
for granted
yet you realize that
the wagon was uh the primary source of
transportation
for all settlers who in the western
region think about the actual wagon and
the bench you sit on and the big wooden
wheels and
yeah yeah yeah it does it doesn't
interest you no it does it's certain to
take all comedy of like ha ha tig that's
boring no out of the picture no no i i
do think um gonna be hard to get 15
episodes i think you need to start with
your narrative special saying hello
hotel guest and welcome hello hotel
guest yeah and welcome
i understand that uh you have peculiar
tastes which is why i'm
thrilled to welcome you i hope you've
boiled the top sheet on the bed
before we begin that's what i always do
uh and i hope you've burned the
comforter cause god knows that's never
real that's never been cleaned the only
hotel guest not watching forensic files
and watching a wagon i love forensic
files yeah but a forensic files about
the wagon yeah would be fine the history
of wagons
narrated by
conan o'brien right ah the wagon ah the
wagon
the mighty warrior of the west
so often take it for granted but not on
this show over the next 75 episodes
we'll start with the wheel we'll go to
the axle then to the springs and then if
i try to cushion the bench the springs
there's no spring on the wagon i think
there was not in the 1800s oh there was
springs weren't invented in the 1800s
whenever i am around a television and i
tell stephanie wait wait go back she was
always like would you see a wagon